want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you two you have michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and get some
amazing motivation from the one and only
grant cardone
enjoy
[Music]
the only thing i can control my life are
the things that i'm willing to take
responsibility for these gladiators that
came here thousands of years ago and
maybe lost their lives if they took
responsibility for the match full
responsibility and i might be taking
this too far right now i don't know i
don't know what it was like to be a
gladiator in 720 740 a.d okay i can't
even imagine fighting in front of 50 000
people with lions possibly coming out to
eat me okay but i know this you really
got to get this point carried away you
got to get it like in your head you're
an executive you're a business owner
you're a manager you're trying to hire
people you're trying to hire people and
you're like oh the people are bad
everybody's terrible everybody's bad i
can't find good people to take
responsibility we all have something to
do with what's going on around us
you and i authorize others
to drop the bomb look i've been robbed
twice in my life 23 years old i was
almost killed guy came in my house put a
45 caliber pistol in my face
hit me right here then put 70 stitches
in my head and face robbed me
in new orleans louisiana i was robbed
at a younger age
i caused both of those i was the victim
in both situations on the police report
victim
robbed by
criminals truth is i wasn't a victim i
created both of those wrong place wrong
time wrong people i had something to do
with that
everything that happens to you is
because of you
quit passing it off
right it's going to rain on me right now
while i'm shooting this
dude that's my fault i could have shot
this thing yesterday when it was
sunshine
watch and read high-performance people
and you will see that they always take
responsibility when their life goes to
to garbage it's when they quit taking
responsibility the greats in the world
keep track of everything when they're in
the game
when they're the gladiator when they're
the ballplayer when they're the
executive of a big company they're
statizing everything okay how many
outbound how many inbound uh what's our
closing ratio what's our right ratio
everything is measured measure your
actions and measure your results those
that don't and won't are irresponsible
and they
will cause you problems
i remember as a young salesperson i was
keeping a log not on what i sold but on
what i said to people i kept everything
how many people i talked to how many
people i weighed on how many people i
wrote up how many people i negotiated
with how many people i closed how many
people i talked to on the phone and also
what they said and what i said what
worked and what didn't work i was taking
responsibility this is the only way you
can take responsibility by the way
you can't just say oh i'm responsible
you got to do something to follow up the
responsibility
it's how i handle
and learned and became a professional
salesperson i handle the future by
handling by being responsible for the
present
you go in that gladiator you go in there
as a gladiator in that coliseum okay and
you don't figure out how you lost that
last fight you're gonna die on the next
one take responsibility even if the
other guy cheated
he surprised you he shocked you he
pulled out some other weapon you didn't
know about be prepared for the future by
taking responsibility for the president
so be responsible be the cause not the
effect be responsible
even when you're not responsible be
responsible bad things happen to good
people good things by the way happen to
good people and blame no one be
responsible and remember this you want
to be great you want to be super
successful take responsibility for
everything
even the things that you could have no
responsibility for
everybody can do more you know and you
don't know what you can do until you see
other people doing big stuff and and
that's why today like we started this
talking about
in the past i'd look up to people want
to pull them down now i'm like wow dude
that's an inspiration yeah and i look
for people like all the way back to
jesus is an inspiration to me like he
left his town
you know i've used that jesus analogy
him leaving bethlehem did he leave
bethlehem or nazareth
now there's
some something right so i'm like you
know what nobody would know him if he
didn't leave home i've i've moved from
lake charles to houston houston to san
diego san diego to l.a l.a to miami i
might move again every move has been
good for me
so you got to leave your home you got to
leave your comfort you know you got to
walk the path and you got to get a team
yeah you need you can't do anything
great by yourself
and uh and i truly believe all of us no
matter where you are today you can do
everybody can do ten times more than you
think you can
and before you get to 10x you'll end up
changing the goal to 10 times more if
you're young whatever that means i would
quit telling people your age like i
would not lead when i'm 12 or i mean i'm
only 22. don't open with that nobody
cares about your age the only thing
anybody cares about is their own age
like i've never thought how old is rob
moore
never ever even even like never
considered that because i don't care how
old you are i care how old i am you know
and and that's that's a fact of life
that people
you know
alexander the great was 16 years old he
took over persia he didn't he didn't
send a notice hey by the way i'm only
16.
you know like not something it's not
good to leave with that
what you want to lead with is your
ability to get attention
and hook somebody okay when my kids
tonight last night we were at dinner
here and these guys that i'm at dinner
with they've seen they've met everybody
you you name them if they're an american
president they met them
and this one guy looks at my daughter
sabrina says
man she is freaking amazing she's ten
he's like i've met him all he's like
as an amazing human being but it's
because she knows how to communicate
right how to get attention and hold it
how to keep it if you learn to love the
thing you hate you might find a big gift
in it and for me i didn't like sales i
hated it i tried selling when i was 17
years old
lost a job
18 i tried again part time during the
summer lost the job
19 years old lost the job i had had five
experiences in sales and hated every one
of them all different industries i just
kept moving industries thinking okay
it'll be different
this will be easy to sell i hated sales
i hated talking to people i particularly
hated the beginning the rapport building
you know i'm not good at breaking ice
like ron secco he can talk to anybody i
can't do that i can't go into a room um
i could speak to 35 000 people but i
can't go into a room and start warming
it up
it's just i'm uncomfortable so
the point i'm trying to make is when i
was 25 the only job i could get was a
sales job and i said hey you got to
decide that you're going to get good at
this even if you hate it
because you can't lose another job it
would have been my sixth of firing and
i'm like i cannot lose another job i did
by the way get fired from that place but
they never got rid of me because i kept
selling yeah so every time they'd fire
me i'd be i'd go back and sell something
they'd be like
stay another day until the next time you
mess up something so you know i went
from hating sales
to committing to it to becoming now
known as like one of the greatest living
sales people on the planet
so
in the things you hate yeah like where
does the hate come from like the things
that you hate
the things that just grind you out like
you're gonna just bug you there's
probably if you just stay with it and
look just move to the side a little bit
and look behind it there might be some
what is the the mindset you would share
with anyone who's 40 50 or 60 and be
above who hasn't
accomplished what they want yet
what would you say to them
based on what you've learned after 50.
you know i used to tell myself i would
never have anything to contribute to the
world until i was 50.
because i'm very immature i've always
been described as a rough diamond like
like rough around the edges
abrasive
not much of a filter you know i i am i
mean i know everything that people say
negative about me for every one thing
every the public has i i know i know
every one of them
there's nothing anybody ever says about
me that surprises me i'm like yeah i
know that
like you guys don't think i know that i
live with me every day late
i did actually did not think i would
have anything to contribute worthwhile
until i was 50 years old
and uh that was about the time the
economic uh collapse was the great
recession and i was so lost in that
financially i didn't understand i was
actually being farmed right there i was
being matured i was being prepared for
what whatever's going on in my life
right now
really the the creation of grant cardone
has happened in the last 10 or 12 years
not
not before that
the grant cardone people know today is
being being developed right now
and i would just tell people that are
older like
dude you're going to have more energy
later unless you don't
you're going to have more genius later
unless you refuse to
you're going to have the ability to
influence more unless you refuse to
influence
and age has got nothing to do with the
game like nobody really knows my age
like
i was 50 years old when i was in pueblo
i told everybody i'm 50 years old my
name's louis curtis i have two kids
beautiful two kids i got a wife named
ava
had made up names for the kids i had to
make up all that story
and we live in la and i hate it
because if i told people i was me in
miami
if anybody went and searched it
and started doing you know images like
people do all that stuff today
i know
so um i would just tell people man you
look i look at people that are 80 years
old i'm like dude i got 20 years left
you know how much damage i could do in
20 years i know guys are in great shape
uh dolly parton i mean she's still
hammering she never did nine to five
she made some money on a song called
nine to five
you know but she's been doing five to
nine for for years so i just think
people can get better if they want to or
they can get worse you're either gonna
decay
are you going to reboot yourself over
and over again so
this is what you got to do to play the
game one you got to be committed
you got to be like hey i need to learn
about real estate you can't do real
estate bitcoin stocks like you can't do
everything you'd be great at one thing
you just be a half-assed player at all
everything
and you'll never go hard enough on one
thing to ever make you any big money you
know what i'm saying i mean if you're
going to play the crypto thing then you
need to know which crypto's going to win
they're not all going to win
and then you need to go hard and heavy
on that one thing real estate
for 30 years i've been studying the real
estate game and i mean i just
i know this game now
i got the eye
i'm looking for the barriers to entry
i'm looking for scarcity i'm looking for
irreplaceable
and i'm looking for something where i
can value add add value to the property
without spending a lot of money i'm
gonna probably spend 150 000 on the
landscaping of this pool that could be
worth five large to me
that's a 40 35 x return
i got to be able to pay for it
i got to be able to see it
i got to be able to commit to it but how
you going to see the deal if you're
looking at everything you're not
so i'm on the ocean in miami
i know the best property in miami's got
sand in front of it
there's plenty of condos there's nothing
you can really do with a condo
only thing you do with a condo is get a
good price on it
and hope to sell it hope to sell it for
something later on a property like this
you could actually overpay for a
property like this if you got the i the
i or the real estate investor the rei
so look if you want to learn oh look at
that pelicans flying overhead man
beautiful
if you want to learn the game the way i
know it this is a simple simple game
okay
available to men women black brown white
hispanic you name it it doesn't matter
who you are where you are it doesn't
matter what your religion or education
is
okay it doesn't even matter if you got a
credit score seriously or money down you
got to know what you're looking for
because if you find the right deal you
can find money for it these are the
things they don't teach you in school
dude commit first figure the rest out
later commit first okay commit first
figure rest out later money is an
illusion money is an illusion there's so
much money on this planet
there's more money on this planet than
our people there's more money on this
planet than there are planes there's
more money on this planet than phones
there's more money on this planet than
cattle
there's no shortage
but there is a shortage of people
committed to it there's a shortage of
creativity and strategy this is why i
don't buy houses okay this is why brent
brandon seen this presentation before
okay this is my favorite topic in the
universe
because because because this this is
what allows me this is what allows me to
move okay so when i buy 15 when i take
15 million dollars
okay i buy 60 million dollars worth of
real estate
15 million
buys 60 million dollars for the real
estate okay
okay
well and we we i'm not buying i'm not
buying 60 million deals so i'm buying
i'm buying i'll i'll do i'll do a
billion dollars worth of real estate
this year okay y'all can y'all look at
that number
okay this is what i'm gonna do this year
so i'm gonna take 300 million dollars
this year
and i'm gonna buy 1.2 billion dollars
worth of real estate
to me it's a good deal
i can become a billionaire
i can own a billion control a billion
dollars worth of assets
for 300 million all i got to do is
figure out how to get 300 million
dollars
goddamn this is like god this is all the
math i needed i could have learned this
in a fifth grade
don't need any any i don't need any
algebra no trigonometry calculus don't
need any of this multiplication
leverage 300 million dollars worth of
cash
buys 1.2 billion worth of real estate in
america okay
that 300 million dollars is going to pay
me
18 million a year
in cash flow
is that right i think that's right
i'm going to get paid 1.5 million
dollars every month
to control 1.2 billion worth of real
estate okay this is cash flow cash flow
is what
it's freedom baby it's freedom it's flow
it's current
it's a current currency the word
currency comes from current
if you look it up in the dictionary
current it has to move
see this right here the 1.2 billion is
not moving
that's good too though that's good
because you want something this
this ill-liquid
that will grow right this is the flow
the flow allows me to keep the asset
until it appreciates
we're looking for unusual activity
okay there's unusual activity going on
right now
it you see it every day if you're
looking for it
people are moving out of new york
entire companies are starting to move
new jersey they're complaining about it
okay they're pissed off as hell the
government they changed the rules on um
writing your state taxes off against
your federal
now what's that called uh
salt
so it used to be that i paid 13 in
california and then i'm paying 48 in in
federal i could take the 13 off the 48.
now it's not like that now it's 13 or 48
or 38 or 39 whatever it's terrible
okay so
i take 300 million dollars
cash
it's worth the last 10 years from now
how many believe this 300 million is
worth less than 10 years
you don't need another math class it's
you know it's going down in value
i take the cash the trash
and i buy concrete steel and glass
where people live okay we don't buy any
retail nothing no macy's no
bloomingdale's maybe one day but not
today
these people have to have a place to
live when we buy this asset it is cash
flowing
we know it's going to make a six percent
in in the first year five to seven
percent somewhere in that range we
should be paid on that deal okay so so
this is really important this cash flow
right here this cash flow is what will
get you through a contraction you have
to have cash flow to assist you through
contraction you're around people that
say hey money won't make you happy
i'm with you it ain't gonna make you
happy
but it'll buy a nice villa
that you can bring your kids
and some support and some staff
where you guys going
okay have fun
it'll give money money money matters
okay the last thing i'm gonna tell you
is that money matters and you gotta get
your money right okay don't waste it
don't lose it
use it
money don't waste it
don't lose it
use it
use it to make yourself better if you
have a business use it to make yourself
better and the business better use it to
make yourself better the business better
hire employees use it to make yourself
better the business better to hire
employees make them better use it to
make yourself better the business better
the employees better and then add more
employees and then
use it to market your company market
yourself to reach new connections use
money to go out and meet the people that
dream bigger than you do and that have
done all these things i'm telling you
which is they're not wasting the
weekends and they're paying the price
and i promise you'll end up with a life
that'll be beyond anything you can dream
or imagine i can't wait i can't wait
when i really started learning from the
in the beginning what what you learn is
you're learning from the master
you know and and so i'm i'm duplicating
and emulating then at some point you
cross over and you become the master
and and if if you're a guy like me i'm
always looking to improve everything i'm
looking for another little tweak another
little twist you and i did that with the
podcast i'm looking for that that next
thing all the time how to make something
just a little better
a little faster
and so at some point i kept studying
this guy until i was able in the
beginning i didn't challenge anything i
used
i duplicated
i got let me tell the script that i that
i learned let me use exactly what he's
telling me to do do it
i whatever whatever i heard i'm i'm
gonna be like i'm gonna make that work
that's gonna be my stable datum
and once i could re once i could trust
that then i could build on top of it i
never yeah butted anything oh i got a
better way in the beginning dude until i
got the results over and over consistent
results
then i started
then i started teaching it to other
people then i started learning angles
you kind of alluded to like your your
belief system your spirituality what
does that believe real quickly i mean
like just you know put it in the words
yeah i believe that i'm a spiritual
being and you know and and and i'm in a
body and and but but but but i'm not a
body i'm not a brain i'm not a piece of
meat i'm not bones i'm not five eight
i'm not 170 pounds
you know i'm i'm beyond time and and
energy and
measurable units
so i'm not i'm not really grant that's
my name that was given to my given to me
the these things that i've done the cars
that i drive
it's just stuff like the the undercover
billionaire was extremely
spiritually liberating
adventure for me really i saw because i
lost everything i didn't have my money
didn't have the roles didn't have the
g63 didn't have the gulfstream didn't
have my name dude didn't have my social
media you know didn't have my hair
didn't have my my goodies you know i
didn't have 150 people on my team i
didn't have
it was me
and i'm like damn dude like i don't need
anything yeah i'm in a new environment
when nobody knows me and like it was so
empowering because i'm like i am truly
like i am capable of taking care of
myself without money without credit
cards
with just communication
you know i think even in success some
people luck up right i mean the rights
they don't know they don't know i i 100
agree with what you're saying
like and they wonder can i do it again
yeah
there's that doubt
could i do it again and you know when
the when discovery went to help me out a
little bit like because they're
producing a show like let's keep it real
it's
i'm like i don't want your help and
they're like no no we gotta we got a
meeting for you with so-and-so i don't
want it cause for you to say about a
show throw it in the trash i don't want
it
and they're like well no they it's gonna
be good tv i cannot take your help
and they're like wow we're trying to
help you i'm like yeah you understand
once i take your help i can't help me
once you help me then i become relying
on your help
tomorrow i'm gonna wake up and say can
you help me three days from now and be
like hey why aren't you helping me like
like i become i become disabled money
follows attention when i get enough
attention money will follow it if i can
get enough people to listen to me
somebody will say hey i want to sponsor
an ad because there's so many people i
just did a deal this weekend it took
like that long because of my audience
i want to give this much money and i
want to give you options in my company
and i'm just going to cross my fingers
and hope good stuff happens
but he sees me interacting with all
these people and converting people right
so money follows attention if i can get
really bright over here money will go to
that
if it's a good cause if it's a bad cause
it's not going to work okay but what
happens is
the the the the attention wanes
way if you can spike the money game the
money the attention will follow again
uh people pay a lot of money to be in
the super bowl or a big soccer game
right because
there's a lot of people there
so if you could learn how about
algorithms getting eyeballs keeping
eyeballs surveys learning how to keep
people's attention man you're gonna
you're gonna be unbelievable and it
won't matter how old you are by the way
it took me a long time to understand
that i had limiting beliefs especially
when i was doing well so when i started
making 80 and 90 000 a year in sales
this is many many years ago that's like
270 000
today in an industry by the way where
the top producers were 40 000 the
limiting beliefs that i had at that time
and then even when i was making a
million dollars a year were the ones
when i was making money you know when
you're not making any money it's clear
you got a limiting belief you know
you're making 30 grand a year and that's
all you can make no matter how good you
are no matter how much you smile no
matter how much service you provide no
matter how early you get there how late
you stay and you still make 30 you know
there's a limiting belief because
everything would indicate you should be
paid more when you're making a million
dollars a year you start thinking i
don't have any limiting beliefs so the
way to handle that is you need to study
people that have created massive amounts
this is exactly what the 10x rule was
about create massive amounts in the
millionaire booklet it talks about
earning money keeping money and
multiplying money this is what the great
sales people don't do i know great sales
people that have never figured out how
to multiply money i know salespeople
that are so good like i'm like dude that
guy is probably a better sales person
than me but he's still broke he's broke
because he made his money didn't know
how to keep it
or he kept it didn't know how to
multiply it how much you earn is a
limited belief how you keep it where you
keep it is the limiting belief if you
have money in the bank or equity in your
house or you have a retirement account
you have a limiting belief about money
you're saving for a rainy day you have
equity in your home waiting to pay it
off in 30 years completely ridiculous no
no high performance person needs to
worry about paying their house off you
should rent where you live own
stuff that other people pay you for okay
and just rent where you live and be
mobile and the third thing is you know
planning for having cash sit in an
account just sitting dead in an account
or in your wall or underneath your bed
or in your safe or the vault wherever it
is but what about an emergency if your
money's in the bank and the internet
goes down you won't be getting your
money out there's no getting the money
if you got it underneath your bed what
what what for like some of you are
storing money in gold gold is a limiting
money belief you're like oh my god the
world's gonna come to an end gold will
not help you out of the end of the world
scenarios you should make a whole list
of all the limiting beliefs that you
have around money number one number two
you should most importantly make a list
of limiting actions
not limiting beliefs because your
beliefs are turning into actions how you
save money how you spend money how you
invest money diversification is also a
limiting belief okay now i know a lot of
people recommend diversification
especially the people on wall street
that benefit from you diversifying the
most
they don't want you all eggs in one
basket but if you study the super
wealthy they took stakes once they got
super rich then they're like okay i own
the railroads the banks
and all the grocery stores so when when
kovit happened in the country shut down
i flew in i told i told my guys i'm like
hey guys i want to get rid of an entire
department 43 people and they're like
you're overreacting i said good sleep on
it we'll talk tomorrow
okay so the next morning i call them at
eight o'clock i'm like are you guys
ready to let kill the department no
we're not i said well good kill the
department it's not your call it's my
call wow i don't need your support on it
eliminate the department there was two
reasons i did that number one i needed i
needed our attention by the way it is
the dream department of this company
i've tried to put this department
together for seven years and failed
and i'm still going to do it it's a big
dream of mine so i had to give up a
dream of mine now this is this is one of
my principles of success
dude if you want to move give up
something
give something up surrender something
you love like
43 people did lose their job okay it's
terrible 40 million would lose their job
in the next four months
my 43 were the first
i was probably the first person to let
people go in america i would louis every
morning for 10 years i said today's the
last day i'm never going to use again
15 minutes 10 years 10 years uh nine
years and in nine years and like six
months so what was the deciding factor
that actually made you quit i finally
went you know i had to go some some
place i had to change my environment so
i went to a treatment center in
minneapolis
during the winter time
late february i was 25 years old and
spent 28 days there
in an environment where nobody had drugs
i didn't have access to drugs
and people were starting to talk about
okay how did you get here
they ended up putting me on drugs in the
treatment center
and i'm like i don't want the drugs dude
they're like oh no you needed to detox
to get off i'm like this this was 30
years ago like they've really ramped
that program up now
it's the legal legal drug dealer now is
the treatment center but but the
environment gave me at least
i was able to look around and see the
damage drugs were causing these other
people men and women of all ages
and then that really solidified okay i'm
stopping but i needed i needed a day one
day not to use drugs because i had been
using drugs every day for nine years
nine and a half years wow and so i
needed the first day once i got the
first day i'm like [ __ ] i can put
together two days then my head started
clearing up a little bit 28 days later i
go home to lake charles louisiana and
that's when the rebuilding really took
place and and i had to replace all that
drug time which was a bunch of hours
every day this is what made me the beast
like the savage that i am today i made a
launch out i was in a middle-class
family raised by a single mother we had
a roof over our head three meals a day
uh i had all the love i could do but we
had no money
and when you don't have money you have
fear
when you don't have the right vehicle
when you're in a vehicle you're working
real estate and the most you can make is
three percent and they're gonna chop you
you know they're gonna chop you you know
the seller's gonna
cut you up three percent you got me two
million over asking
and you want three six percent and i
gotta split it with my wife
right
how many of you get chopped up
you're getting chopped up because you're
not professional enough yet
when they're still asking for your fees
they are saying hey you are still not
the player that i that deserves a full
fee
so you got to change your game now man
particularly with inventory problems
that you have right now you're going to
continue to have this inventory problem
folks this is not going away housing
prices over the next decade will not go
down they will go up they will continue
to go up you're looking in a rear view
mirror thinking about what oh i should
have bought everything
because you should have by the way
but you didn't
because you didn't sell enough to have
enough to buy enough
right and you were sitting in the market
you were sitting in the market how many
times have you said this is a good deal
how many of your room has said that
before this is a good deal
why don't you buy it
oh cause you can't
because you didn't
so you didn't do enough to put yourself
in your family in a situation where you
could and that's what happened to me in
2010 i had not done enough i had three
successful businesses all three of them
got cut off because
of this mortgage thing you got to commit
first when you know something's right
folks commit
commit
go all in on the deal nobody knows what
you're what you're up to nobody knows
what's going on inside me i called my
mom that night and i said i met my wife
today and she's like
have you all been out where did y'all go
what did you do i said no she hates me
and she's like she hates you grant it
takes two and this is what i knew from
being in business and if you're taking
notes it might be worthwhile it does not
take two to tango
it does not take two to make a marriage
and it does not take a buyer and a
seller what it takes is you
it needs to be you first you have to
decide they're selling the house and you
got to decide that they're buying the
house before any house makes a
transaction i had to decide that she was
going to be the girl before she could
see that i was going to be the guy you
guys with me all right 26 phone calls
all of them were light hey how you doing
you know i didn't mention that she never
calls me back
i didn't mention that she was breaking
my heart every time she didn't call me i
didn't mention the fact that her best
friend said i was too short
okay
you guys know what all your objections
are don't you like her a friend said
you're too short i said just tell me
what the real deal is i got to know what
the objection is i cannot handle the
unspoken objection what is the real deal
grant you're too sharp i said okay what
else what else you got
uh you're not a hollywood guy she's
she's an actress i wasn't in hollywood
i'm not an actor okay good what else
you're a businessman she thinks you're
too conservative okay what else what
else you got well you don't have a
prison record
you don't have a prison record no
tattoos she like bad boys okay how many
ladies here like the bad boys
just be honest
okay be honest the lady over here is
like yes
i love them okay so so i just continue
to pursue her because like somebody said
earlier sometimes people change
how many of your room have changed
how many of your room have changed
exactly you're going to keep changing
too some of you you're not going to like
so so
i pursued her until one day because i
know this okay and you might want to
keep this in your collection of how you
handle
discouragement along the way
when you get a no would you agree that
no is a version of yes
many would agree with that
dude look i mean think about it what's
the opposite of yes
what's the opposite of no
what's in between
maybe
so i always tell people when they tell
me no i'm like don't say no
say maybe
okay just say maybe well maybe grant
maybe but not right now excellent
because i know no's can turn into yeses
i said no to a lot of things in life and
then done them you've walked into a
casino before i am not gambling tonight
i will not gamble you came down to cabo
i am not drinking while i'm here
okay you some of you came down no
enriched bread while i'm here
no chips no guacamole nothing okay and
as soon as you got down here you're just
like freaking hitting shots
eating guacamole slamming it in your
face right
so how do you get from no to yes
just show up in cabo
it's a maybe
right how do you get somebody to say go
go from not selling their house to yes i
will
get to a maybe
and then follow them up yeah so best
advice i have received my mom said hey
invest in yourself you'll never lose
i have reminded myself of that
so many times workshops i go to
events that i attend where i'm going as
somebody to get educated okay books that
i've read i'm like it's not a waste of
time
even even if you don't think you learn
anything it is not a waste of time you
think you think you haven't
that it was a waste of time or you
didn't learn anything because you hadn't
used it yet
you may use that piece of data one day
and so number one anything you invest in
time or or
or money in trying to improve yourself
you're not gonna lose that the beauty
salon the restaurant the bar the bar
owner
um the consultant we've all had the
experience of
resenting our customers starting not to
like them
and it's because we become dependent
upon them
we have too few if we're resenting our
customer what is that saying about us
that we're not building our brand that
we're not growing that we're not selling
enough yeah you didn't go you didn't you
didn't build the top of your funnel out
enough
because this this part of it's easy
even though you hate them they never pay
you money this is the kind of stuff that
goes on they don't pay me enough they
always complain they never use the
product no matter what i do for them
they [ __ ] and complain okay they're
never happy blah blah blah right
well the truth is those are indications
that you didn't build your your customer
base wide enough
because you now resent them your
resentment is an indication that you
rely on them too much
and every time they complain to you it
reminds you that i'm too reliant on too
little and and we've all done it we all
do it i've done it uh right now i'm
doing it in my real estate i told my guy
ryan the other day i said we're
depending on this one guy too much
and he's like why do you say that
because i'm starting to resent him
so what's the first thing we should do
what are the what's the action steps
after that when we resent our customers
you got it you got to understand it's
not about them it's about you
has nothing to do with them you need to
go wide you need to go get more
customers
if you resent facebook if you if
facebook pisses you off
it is because you are too
reliant on facebook you know it's
money's pretty simple too how do you get
it how do you keep it how do you
multiply it most people most people
spend their whole life just getting it
they never know how to keep it
um
i mean we don't even understand basic
stuff that currency is basically
uh comes from the word current where
something is moving you don't actually
get to
have own money you don't own the money
the money is gonna go some other place
and um so yeah it's unfortunate but
we're taught nothing on that subject how
do you
build wealth
and stay happy at the same time
well number one is i don't think you
know
money will not make you happy like if
you're not happy you're not happy so
it'll make you jubilant and it'll make
you giddy for a second you know if i
dropped off 100 million
you know at your feet right now uh it
would definitely change your attitude
for a bit
but sooner or later you're coming back
you're coming back to your your your
happiness level
i've never tried to get money to make me
happy ever i have never thought oh i'm
going to go get x money this much money
and i'm going to somehow be happier i've
never ever
i don't even know where this concept
came from
the the connection between the two
you know i go to the gym i think i'm
gonna build muscle
i go to the water fountain i think i'm
gonna quench a thirst
i go to a football game i think i'm
gonna be entertained
i get money i never think about okay i'm
gonna get 10 million bucks
and i'm gonna suddenly be happy
i never i'll never even think about it
like that i'm gonna get 10 million
and then i'm going to invest it and i'm
going to pick up 30 million on the next
swing and i'm gonna take 30 million and
convert that to 90 million i'm going to
take that and convert it into 270 and
i'm going to get to you know blah blah
blah right and then what am i going to
do with it but
dude
i'm never thinking about it it's going
to make me happy your biggest expense in
business
if you got a talent or you got a
business your
biggest expense
is number one your taxes
what the wealthy know is how to reduce
their tax bill that's what you don't
know that you got to get a handle on
reduce your tax bill to literally zero
and beyond that's right beyond that's
where you would get tax refunds or
credits going forward to reduce your
income
tax
federal and state to zero how do you do
that
i'm going to show you
[Music]
anybody can do it it's completely legal
and if you don't do it come on
you're just not you're just not
following the tips of the wealthy i
didn't grow up with wealth
i grew up and had to figure out
how to take my talent
increase my income reduce my tax bill
and then get
my money to work for me harder than i
worked
for my damn money the goal is to take
your earnings reduce it to zero still
have the money
but take the money
and invest it
so let's say you're earning two million
dollars a year
if you live in new york city one million
dollars of that
is going to the irs that means you got
to figure out how to live on 1 million
dollars
and if you're a ball player out of that
cane 200 grand for an agent another 200
grand probably for a manager and you're
having to live on 800 000 if you buy a
house for your mother you're freaking
broke again so i'm going to show you how
to play the game
you earn two million okay
live on as little of this money as you
can in the beginning do not spend earned
income don't spend it what you do is you
invest it and use it in a second
business and or real property so let's
say i take 200 million the state's going
to take you're still going to have your
400 000 go to agents and managers
you got 1.6 million dollars i want you
to invest as much of that 1.6 million
dollars into real property
real property will buy you about 4.8
million dollars worth of in this case
real estate
that 4.8 million dollars worth of real
estate because it's got real property
4.8 million dollars for instance in a
deal that i'm doing right now will
provide you with 2.4 million dollars
worth of depreciation
that reduces this tax bill
of 1.6 after your managers these are
expenses
to negative 800
000
that can be
cf carry forward into future years that
means next year if you earn two million
dollars you're walking into that year
with an 800 000
credit against your income now you need
to check with your
tax attorney
you need to check with your accountant
you need to check with your manager and
your agent but i'll promise you all for
them we're going to tell you this guy's
on to something get your earned income
earned income
needs to be zero and passive income
[Music]
i need to invest in a new whiteboard
your passive income of the
what do we say 1.6 million dollars that
we invested that we have left over we
literally i'm i'm encouraging your
littering no watches
no houses in the beginning okay don't
spend any money on the stuff no ferraris
take the 1.6 leverage it it'll about 4.8
million dollars for the real property
okay you want to stay focused on your
baseball your basketball your rapping
you want to focus on your business or
maybe you want to invest this money back
in your business and zero out okay you
want to reinvest in furniture equipment
uh if you're a musician into
equipment touring
anything to do with your business to
grow your business literally get your
earned income to be
zero the tax bill on zero is zero 61
percent of all
citizens in the united states last year
made
no contribution to the federal income
taxes
your job is to make sure that you take
your earned income because you got a lot
of talent
[Music]
reinvest that money okay so that you can
be better talent and or prepare for
transition when you no longer have that
talent so this 1.6 million dollars of
earned income after your agent
and your manager you would invest and
leverage three to four times
by 4.8 million dollars worth of real
estate that would give you 2.4 million
dollars worth of depreciation
in the first year it's a little
complicated now this is called
accelerated depreciation this is the
game this is the game that the wealthy
know how to use and that's why they tend
to use
all their earned income okay some of the
biggest players in the world they pay
themselves zero one dollar a year i
think mark zuckerberg makes one dollar a
year but he gets stock options
real property
this 2.4 million dollars of depreciation
you get in 2021
if you use it all you'll get it again in
22 if you don't use it all you'll get it
again in 2023 and you're going to
continue to do this every year okay i'm
going to continue to do the same
mechanism every year reinvesting earned
income okay so stay with me here okay
watch what's going to happen this 4.8
million worth of real estate remember
this it's in the box
you own that that's your position okay
this 1.6 million dollars that you
invested should provide you with about
90 000 a year in income
passive income okay that's in year one
if you do this again in year two it's
going to get you another 90 000 a year
in passive income that's 180 grand by
year two but in year two you now have
nine 9.6 million dollars
worth of real estate real property that
should be appreciating in value
providing you and your family with
passive income now now we're at about 15
000 a month in passive income and you're
starting to prepare third year fourth
year fifth year now you're at 75 000 a
month in passive income you're gonna
exit your career because
look you got five years maybe at max
ball players artists you don't have
forever you're not going to be a 35-year
baseball player a basketball player
so if you start multiplying these years
in year two i'm at 180 000 in year four
i'm at 360.
year eight i'm at 700 grand
in passive income per year
and that is not counting the value of
the real property which in this case if
i can take this out eight years
if you could duplicate this every year
and not get a pay raise every year eight
years eight times if we did this every
year 4.8 million dollars
you've paid no taxes for eight years
in a perfect situation
and that would be 38 million four
hundred thousand dollars worth of real
estate
that is going up in value every year
this just goes up three percent a year i
could take this out and i say in the
next
10 to 15 years you'll have 100 million
dollars worth of real estate
throwing out passive income most the
passive income is now
not taxed at the highest rates it's it
is somewhere as low as 19 percent a year
where you're paying 48 to 63 depending
on whether you live in l.a or new york
or one of these crazy states so
happiness for me comes from doing
personally yeah yeah it comes from
accomplishing things
like i experience my happiness when when
i accomplish something i'm proud of
so when we do a conference and i walk
away
and i'm
thrilled at the event we put on the
quality the lights you know that feels
good you know when the people around me
are happy when i look around when i'm
proud of who i'm being and doing every
day you know that makes me happy seeing
my kids my kids are
i'm so proud of my kids they're such a
you know a validation that i'm a good
guy when i can't see the good guy in me
i can look at sabrina and scarlet say
hey you got to be a good guy to produce
those
[Music]
i have i have a couple businesses this
year we'll do 150 million dollars
my real estate we have 2.5 billion worth
of real estate that we own that produces
cash flow almost 10 000 units that that
2200 bucks a month do the math on that
things are very good at our place and
i'm like
why don't you become a real estate agent
okay average real estate agent makes
what 25 000 bucks a year or something
25 000 a year okay right something like
that
it's sad
it's sad and i want to talk to you about
the finances right now okay
somebody said about not chasing
squirrels i think she was talking about
chasing other opportunities is that
right okay but also you guys need to
think about not chasing squirrels that
don't get your opportunity here because
they're squirrels they're gathering nuts
like oh i can't i can't i don't want to
put signs up i'm like dude move on
you need people i need people in my life
that are heavily financially motivated
i hear everybody talking about their
wives and their kids and and oh my god
life is to be lived you cannot live on
this planet without money folks
okay nowhere can you go and buy
something the yacht
the experience the weekend so you i
would look for people that are
financially motivated that want to make
more money and that understand that
financial illiteracy is what's hanging
people up from their dreams
you got people hey what do you want to
do well i want my time off what are you
going to do with time off you ain't got
any
money the hell man you want to you want
to know the cause of depression
too much time and too little money
give me a job get me a mission get me
something to do give me possibility give
me a payoff if you're not going to train
then put a sign on your desk i quit
learning a long time ago and see how
many people want to buy from
tell your family go home and tell your
wife and your kids i quit learning i
quit reading i quit studying i quit
training i can't get any better
put on there done i'm finished i'm in
retirement early i'm going to purgatory
i'm going to wait it out cross my
fingers and hope they bring me to sales
heaven
look you're done if you don't train okay
now i know you know this you've heard it
i hate to tell you this
my boy mcgregor connor
conor mcgregor or mcgregor my boy conor
mcgregor okay i went and saw him fight
in new york i went and saw him fight for
one reason because i saw him say i'm not
the best this isn't about talent
it's cause i'm obsessed i out train
everyone else i have to win so bad i
train
look if you're not training that says
something about your obsession or lack
of obsession
with winning
i want you to win i know your your wife
or your husband your spouse your family
members your kids your mom and dad want
you to win at the next level no matter
what they tell you
even if they tell you you're doing great
pat you in the back you know the truth
you know the truth the only way to win
is to train the only way to win is to
read the only way to win is to learn
learn more listen more
learn something new look we're in a
we're in a time like we've never been
before
technologies come and go faster than
people do
things are changing like this whether
it's video you're using or social media
or snap or or short videos or videos
that disappear or videos that day or
text messaging that you can create to
push and market and brand yourself
called text messaging which i've been
using a lot
look the world's changing
and if you're saying to yourself i'm too
old to learn that well then guess what
you're too old to learn that if you
can't learn anything new just put i'm
ripe and i'm about to fall off the tree
and nobody's gonna want me look man you
gotta train every single day like your
life depends on it
train every single day i am here
today i own these four companies that i
own the studio my reputation everything
is because when i was 25 years old to
when i was 30 years old every single day
i trained watching video every day i'd
watch the video i'd walk in and then i
would role play and then we would do a
sales meeting every single day and
immediately immediately when i was 25
years old that is what changed my whole
life my commitment to training my
commitment and willingness to sit down
every day take in a piece of data
sit down and roll play that with
somebody else
okay look at my stats every day and on
the way home on the drive home every
single day
i would listen to audio on my way to
work every day i would listen to audio
when i woke up in the morning i watched
video every morning when i got to work i
role played every time i lost the deal i
rolled played what i would do
differently next time to get that deal
that is a commitment
my personal integrity and ethics is why
i can sell so hard
and because i believe in my product i
believe in my investment vehicle i
believe in my company i don't trick
people screw people
like 35 years i've been in business
there's not one person in 35 years that
says i owe them money there's people
that try to get stuff from me using
lawyers and but there's nobody that can
say i ever financially damaged them in
any way not a penny what do you look for
when you're making a real estate
investment if it's anywhere in the world
or yeah yeah yeah what are the key
things i look for cash flow first number
one i look for cash flow because cash
flow will allow me to keep a piece of
property first through the cycles
so number one i want to be paid for
something i do not speculate on real
estate i've never lost a penny investing
in real estate i've been doing this for
35 years
number one i want cash flow number two i
want a great location that's
irreplaceable i care less about the
kitchens and the living rooms
and the exterior the paint the roof i
care nothing about those all those
things can be changed the location can
never be changed and the third thing i
want to know when i buy a piece of real
estate is
who can i sell this to exactly
okay so i should know who i'm exiting
with i should literally know who the
next buyer will be before i purchase the
property if you were an alien looking
down at
the united states of america and saying
okay what is there too much of
restaurants bars and businesses there's
too many of them and then and then
somebody some kid pops up paul pops up
and says i'm going to start a new
business and and the guy from outside
the planet's looking down there saying
well that's stupid why don't you just go
two-thirds of all the businesses in
america break even or lose money so what
i'm hearing you say grant is
a lot of people have the dream of
wanting to start and launch a business
but what i'm hearing you say is it's
probably a lot smarter to go find a
failing business or a business that's
breaking even
jump in add value and see if you can 10x
that dude that's that's how you get on
planes that's how you you know you go to
the hospital you need
emergency care you don't build a
hospital you just go to the hospital you
want food you go to whole foods you want
gas you go to the gas station it's no
different in business
it's a called a going concern for a
reason find a going concern that's got a
brand
go in that's what i did i just went in
and added value
once i added value actually we end up
splitting off another business out of
that what have you learned about the art
of negotiation during you know these
bigger deals for yourself how to
navigate those
you know most these deals are lost over
face they're not even lost over money
they're lost over somebody losing face
i'm doing a deal right now
you mean ego or mean like uh what do you
mean i i can't if i give you any more i
lose face
okay got you so i'm negotiating a deal
right now and i said look if i give this
guy exactly what he wants right now he
still will not do it
and they're like why is that because
he's going to lose face so it's it's
it's people have to win it's almost
never about just the money it's how do i
win
not just financially but how do i win
and feel good about this transaction
because i've done transactions before
where i
supposedly won in the moment
and everybody felt terrible
so it's not a win unless everyone wins
dude everybody needs to win everybody
needs to win something like everybody
needs to feel like good about the
transaction i'd rather pay a little more
and make sure you feel good
then i pay a little less and you feel
bad because i can't do another deal with
you now
and i'm trying to do more deals
and then everybody's got everybody's got
a motivation everyone has a motivation
every buyer has a motivation every
seller has a motivation most of the time
it has nothing to do with the money you
you have to find the motivation
how do you do that quickly for yourself
are you asking certain questions to
figure out what that is are you just
listening to their you know without
asking them what's your motivation how
do you i could i could ask that
other than money what what you know why
what do you need what's your motivation
i could ask them straight up asking
asking those kind of direct questions
are very powerful
hey why would you pick me as a buyer
there's so many other people that could
buy this asset
like that's one i used in the real
estate game these are 100 million dollar
projects what was the first thing you
ever sold when you were a young young
grant the first thing that i the young
grant cardone the first thing i ever
sold was uh i think it was clothes was
it clothes yeah i think i was selling i
was in a clothing store
and i earned six percent on the tie okay
socks and t-shirts um and at that time i
think a tie cost like i don't know maybe
20 bucks so i'd make like 12 cents or
something wow
i was bumped up about it too i was
actually excited i had minimum wage
minimum wage back then was like a dollar
85
and i'd get a little you know
70 cent
commission
right yeah what was yours
what was your first uh real estate
investment my first real estate
investment was a single family home it
was seventy eight thousand dollars i put
three thousand dollars down i thought it
was a genius move
i used three thousand to buy seventy
eight thousand dollars i i thought okay
this is the best thing i i don't even
see how this can be
and uh you know that today would
probably here because it's 20 down now
would probably cost him 15 000 but
that's still a good deal fifteen
thousand dollars i can leverage a 80 000
piece of real estate obviously you can't
buy anything here for 80 000
um more like a million dollars maybe out
in the country yeah yeah not in the city
you're looking
you know millions around yeah but but
but if you could figure out just if you
could just make the transition the
biggest mistake i made in real estate
was i didn't buy enough real estate i
should have bought more real estate i
should have bought it more aggressively
i should have paid more i should have
bought in better locations
because i was thinking too small i was
thinking about the three thousand
dollars i had rather than how could i go
raise the money yeah so look there's no
shortage of money there's a there's a
short a crate a shortage of creativity
and commitment but there's no shortage
of money so you know you got million
dollar properties here how can i go get
gather some family members and some
friends put 200 grand together and own a
piece of real estate that we know is
going to be worth more money in the
future consumer debt is terrible debt
suicide debt that's that's credit card
debt lamborghini buying the lamborghini
on debt uh look if you're going to buy a
lamborghini at lease it for 24 months if
you can't afford the 24 months you can't
afford the lambo debt for clothes
christmas gifts
i mean it's stupid it's stupid to borrow
money for for for this santa claus for
your kids i know people are going to
hate that message that's why so many
people dislike you know they they just
don't like that
it's stupid to go in debt if you want to
do it and uh and for for fun or for
whatever then that's okay but you mean
you're not investing in
a potential greater future no
now if i if i borrow money for santa
claus that's one thing if i borrow money
for
to to invest to to buy to invest in in a
piece of real estate for my kids you
know i mean i know which one's going to
work yeah if you just follow the tax
write-offs you'll know the right thing
to do
i can't write off santa i can write off
the real estate
right so um
yeah bad debt is anything that i have to
then pay the interest rate on
good debt is i made an investment and my
consumer or my tenant is going to pay my
debt that's powerful so you're trying to
you're trying to get more debt you
probably have more debt with me than you
even know
like like because of the investments
you've made with me you have debt you
have good debt
you just don't really know it your
accountant does though because because
we're sending them the k1 at the end of
the year that's why when we send you a
check you don't pay income on that check
that's nice very nice
so you you look at your return but you
know whatever i paid you last year
but that is non-taxable income to you
because of the debt that we have because
of the debts yeah exactly on the asset
exactly michelangelo okay michelangelo
he didn't want a pope but he didn't want
to paint this 16 chapel right dude the
the po the uh the pope said yeah i
understand you don't want to bro start
painting
look what he did yeah yeah right so i
don't know if that's you know i'm just
saying like
i know artists that do what they love
they can't even feed themselves
you know they they love their they love
their wife too or they love their
husband but you can't take care of them
you love your parents but you can't take
care of them so it's just not true if
you just love something if you only do
the things you love there might not even
be any money in it
like you could love horses but
you should have lived like maybe 1400
years ago
and and so falconry we had a falcon tree
guy out here yesterday teaching us about
the birds and the history of it two
hours he spent with us it was freaking
unbelievable
you know but
you know it's a very niche yeah right
yeah
you know 1400 years ago everybody had a
bird yeah you know that that was your
that was the lamborghini of the day
today that's probably not
you could love it but
you're not gonna feed your family with
it 2008 2009 was tough for you just like
it was for a lot of people what was the
lesson you learned then that prepared
you for 2020
that you when the recession hit you said
okay i know exactly what to do based on
that pain in 2008. yeah well i was so
disappointed with myself then like
i had not put my family in a position to
to
flourish and prosper
because of suppression you know the tide
goes out you don't have a boat shame on
you right and i didn't have a boat dude
i mean i had i looked good i looked good
until it happened you got a suit you had
the car i thought i was good i thought i
was good but i was too small small small
always gets hurt
and that that was my big wake-up call in
2008. i didn't have enough assets i
didn't have enough money i my business
was too small my customer base was too
small uh i was too relying on too few
verticals
this was the creation of 10x i blame no
one in 2008 9 and 10. i was like okay
i'm in
i got myself in
this is not about the mortgage crisis
it's not about the builders it's not
about the strippers they've got 17 loans
this is about me i was in this polish i
was in this fear i was i let my family
and myself down
nothing was happening to me
and the most important thing is i was
not in a position to take advantage of
it that's the thing that pissed me off
and so i told elena i said the next time
this happens
dude we're going to freaking rock
and then covet it happened and coveted i
was shooting a tv show and my company
would have the best years i've ever had
wow i wasn't even here
we we bought more assets this year than
we bought the year before we raised more
money this year than the year before it
um you know when when when lehman
collapsed in 2008 i had 50 million
dollars worth of debt i told elaine i
said the next time this hits the fan i'm
gonna have a billion dollars worth of
debt i know i told i said i'm gonna have
a half a billion dollars worth of debt
we had a 1.2 billion dollars worth of
debt when covid hit if i had one thing
to do over again i would be like i would
learn communication skills speaking
skills
debating skills i should have taken a
debating class
because i really don't know how to
debate i just make people wrong
you know
so uh that and that's not debating but i
get away with it somehow you know
uh but but it doesn't work for most
people so people should i would
definitely go back at 18 back to your
first question i would go back and take
debating classes
i would take uh communication classes
i'd probably learn how to code
i would definitely learn how
how these guys are creating funds
spax is a new thing
um
hedge funds
i would learn how to write do surveys
and find out hey what is it people
actually want
and i would learn how to read about
money flows and and people flows in the
internet and algorithms and all this
fascinating stuff but i would i would
only do it for one reason by the way
just so everybody's clear
okay i would only do it so i can make a
lot of money i actually almost threw
away what i had learned and created this
new thing called information assisted
selling information assisted selling
where i started leading with what people
wanted rather than
this guy kind of hid
it was the old school hide it
don't avoid the price bring it up later
and that's where i really started
accelerating everything giving people
the information up front allowing you to
understand how much this watcher ring
was or car was before you even asked
about it i tell you it's 58 000. right
away so you wouldn't wait to the very
end you'd say yeah look look if you're
if you're shopping for a car or a watch
or a ring or a
coaching program whatever it is
you probably want to know how much it is
i know i would this this particular
product is 58 000 it would require about
you know 2500 down your payments would
be about 550 a month
let's be sure you're on the right
product you see i've already i got the
va the value proposition the money i got
you thinking about money right now i
want you thinking about money so that
when i show the product
you can start making sense of it because
i can't convince you that it's worth it
you have to convince you
yeah okay i can build value but you the
buyer is the buyer i can't be the buyer
i can only help the buyer make sense of
it i've somehow figured out
just over time
that i keep adding these little
companies
and i didn't know this it was just kind
of a mistake but all i was looking for
is i didn't want to depend on one flow
of anything okay this was the first
company this was me i was out selling
stuff picking up money
okay next thing i did was i i had a
partnership with a guy right here uh
called cardone the cardone group it's in
orlando florida it's been a partnership
for 25 years guy paid me royalty to use
my name it was passive income i gave him
a majority of the company he sat there
for 25 years and went pumped his deal
used my material okay and then we
created a third company this was the
real estate
i started investing in real estate i
started buying real estate provided me
with a third flow of income now what
happened was i got fat right here
and i got
uh
what's the word
complacent
i'm like okay i'm good started playing
golf three times a week
everything's good um
you know
i'm doing great i'm alan
okay and and and then
and then and then and then and then 2010
came 2008 came like it just
took the little three circles
i didn't have the fourth circle the
fifth circle the sixth circle the
seventh circle i didn't have all these i
didn't have product lineups how many of
you have card on you here let me just
see your hand didn't exist that product
let me see your hand if you have card on
university okay beautiful man look at
the penetration
unbelievable like like you if you want
if you want customer retention get
saturation
don't make people happy make sure they
buy your product
i'm not interested in making people
happy i'm interested having people on my
product
some people you can't make happy it's
impossible they're not happy people
all right so 2010 comes crushes me
i went back to selling
working on that business right there and
buying more real estate and then
creating more companies okay so that i
can start bringing good people in
you understand you gotta you got to keep
expanding you cannot be dependent upon
one thing because that one thing can go
away everybody agree with that
one ad one promotion one person one
product
one of anything well first i quit using
drugs i mean the the the order everybody
wants to get better and have confidence
but the first thing you got to do is you
got to quit doing whatever's destroying
your
destroying your self-esteem you know
i'd like to believe that i could look in
the mirror and tell myself i'm great and
and then i'd feel it but if you're
destroying yourself the other 23 hours
and 56 minutes the self-talk isn't gonna
matter
so i had to quit doing damage to myself
um i hated myself
the worst part of my drug addiction was
how no it wasn't what just what the
drugs were doing to me in in the
hangovers and the lost time and it was
the personal
personal
deprivation
and degrade that i was doing to myself
the guy's house that i'm in right now t
boone's house he died i think he was i
don't know 89 or 90.
but this guy did so much stuff man he he
he would go from being he would he grew
up in poverty becomes worth a couple
billion dollars loses all of it goes
back to like 5 million this guy could
swing so hard but he was very active you
know
he knew all he knew all the presidential
people he was in power
and i'm not saying everybody here needs
to do that but everybody has the
potential to do that
and if you have the potential to do that
you should be in a rush to go do it you
know when we're excited about doing
something you when you're going on a
vacation
you can't even sleep the night before
you're like i'm gonna get up at 5 00 a.m
we're going to go to the airport
you're waking up every 45 minutes is it
time to go
and most people are not most people are
not doing their lives like that today
they're just kind of same thing over and
over
so
yeah man now now i'm running you know
when i was 22 i had all 40 years and now
i'm you know starting to run out of time
and i'm like oh i gotta really get in a
hurry now i'm at the hinsell castle
today hensel castle is a castellated
mansion in the gothic architecture style
dating from the late 17th century some
say maybe the early 18th century i mean
this has got history here so here we are
today in wales talking about the
attitude of service one of the great
great rules of success is to give give
give the attitude of service is the rule
of success that i promise you will
deliver you at levels that you never
imagined possible it's what i built my
career on the ability to give at 100 and
even more and then keep giving nothing
feels as good as giving the more you
give in life in business in
relationships the more you will get from
that relationship from your business and
from the world now i'm not just talking
about money and presence how about
energy people ask me constantly where do
you get all your energy from i get it
from giving how about money the more
money i give away to other people
whether it's employees or charities the
more money i'm going to have it could
also be love or smile or service or even
education when you want to learn
something the best way to learn
something is to start teaching it
sharing it with other people too many
people today they worry too much about
what they get rather than what they can
give to the marketplace to their friends
to their families when i have been most
lost in my life if i go into service i
will find myself i will find my purpose
again now i know what you're thinking
right now if you don't have the money
the finances the energy if you don't
have the friends you want you're like
how can i give anything i don't have
anything to give everyone has something
to give too many people
have their hand out hey what do i get
too many people come to my office what
are you gonna pay me grant what are my
benefits where's my office where's my
desk what's my view people worry about
their dumbest little things you're
always worried about what you get and
guess what when you're worried and
focused about what you get you end up
getting less if you find somebody you
want to work for work with go to them
and say hey this is what i'm going to
give you let me do whatever you need
done and i will get it done trust me
you're not going to be taken advantage
of you're going to get more than you
ever imagined give give give is one of
the great rules of success and when you
give give with sincerity and
authenticity if it's not real from you
if it's not authentic and genuine if
you're not there to give to lots of
people knowing a very few of them will
reciprocate with you and do business
with you if you don't do that with
sincerity it won't work the universe is
set up this way look at the ocean the
tide comes in the tide goes out
everything works like this you give and
you will get back you just have to trust
it and you got to get your presentation
right people know when someone truly
cares i remember the first business i
built when i was 29 maybe 30 years old i
would knock on doors hey my name's grant
i'd like to come in and do something for
your staff to improve their sales to
motivate them to give them strategies
how much is this going to cost me a
young man before anybody knew grant
cardone and i said look it cost nothing
this was my way of introducing myself to
the customer not wanting something in
that moment but wanting to start and
create a relationship people would tell
me hey look are you is this legit is it
really really free people are so
untrusting
why because they haven't given
themselves nothing is as attractive as
someone who is positive and someone that
genuinely wants to make a contribution
and we're not just talking about money
here we're talking about you
contributing your heart your energy a
smile look when you pass a homeless
person somebody that actually needs help
and that homeless person says hey can
you give me some money and you're like
no i'm not going to help you how do you
feel about that if you give them
something even a smile
you will feel better when you keep to
yourself when you don't take the time to
give back then the next few steps you
take after that is you start to withdraw
from people giving to others is like
making deposits in a spiritual bank
account they will pay you back in the
future so where's this 10x thing come
from 10x 10x came from 2008 when the
economy got crushed
i i was in a completely different
financial situation
and where were you i was in los angeles
i lived in lionel richie's house
and dude i had it made like i was living
the life you know dre was my neighbor
leo dicaprio was next door i'm dropping
names down i'm i'm bragging and i throw
it here jenny and uh
and so um
when 2008 happened i had three companies
the first two got crushed and the third
one was just frozen it was a real estate
company i couldn't do anything and my
hands were tired i was like i was like i
went from being
free to trapped
and i said i'll never i got to figure
out what i did wrong
and rather than spending time blaming
the mortgage uh you know the mortgage
crisis and the banks gave bad loans to
people and trying to figure out was it
the clintons or the bushes that did this
to me or whatever the political agenda
was
i said hey what did i do wrong this
always got me out of trouble what did i
do wrong not what did you do to me what
did i do how did i do this to me so i
don't repeat it again one of the things
i built my entire career over one thing
that probably has me responsible for
more deals more closes more companies
more business than any other single
thing i've done in my career
write the deal up okay when i'm buying
real estate i've bought and sold 750
million dollars worth of real estate
every one of them every property i
bought was a sales game it was all a
sales game first i had to get my
finances right second thing i had to do
was make a call follow the guy up he's
trying to sell a property i got to find
out why would you sell it to me how can
i get in his circle of influence okay
how can i get their attention how can i
then follow them up to keep their
attention every real estate deal i've
ever bought
required me to follow up just to buy the
deal which is a sales job three i had to
use my mixed pass to get the deal for i
had to write a deal up i can talk till
i'm blue in the face
there's a there's a guy i wanted to buy
his property he wouldn't respond to my
phone call so what i did was send him an
loi a letter of intent to purchase his
property number four if you don't get to
the write-up nothing matters you guys in
retail you guys and gals in retail if
you're not writing the customer up
you're showing the product presenting
the product walking around the product
and you never write them up you will
never close the deal every deal you have
ever closed in your entire lifetime
guarantee you wrote it up you didn't
talk about it to close it you had them
on a contract on a proposal somebody had
to sign something to buy it you wrote
them up i mean different people have
different ways they invest but they tend
to be more
focused on the long-term appreciation of
an asset
rather than give me money this second
and and i think they get they're they're
not stuck in this get rich quick thing
it's a delayed gratification yeah
they're more like yeah i'd rather have
wealth tomorrow than rich today
and they do have a distinction between
the rich and the wealthy the you know
the super wealthy are looking to create
wealth beyond their own
means and needs like they're not
thinking about their kids their boat
their plane i know people think that but
that's not actually true they're
actually thinking about how do i create
wealth for a lot of people amazon's got
a million employees
yeah now most of them only earn minimum
wage but there's some people at the
upper level of amazon that are making
fortunes i started i sat down and
started right now i'm like if i was 10x
bigger and that's that would if i was 10
times bigger right now
i would have a half a billion dollars
for the debt
551 million dollars
but i only have 51 million dollars worth
of debt that's what i had in 2008.
if i had because the bank called me and
said we need the whole 51 million or
we're going to seize your property i'm
like dude nobody's got 50 million right
now the world's coming to an end
had i owed a half a billion dollars they
wouldn't they wouldn't have treated me
like that they called me said how can we
help you mr carter i want to be sure
everything's all right so i went and
told my wife i said i'm going to write a
book called the 10x rule
and she's like what's the 10x rule the
10x rule basically is i'm going to have
a half a billion dollars worth of debt
the next time and the bank will be my
friend
when covet happened i owed
1.4 billion dollars
to the banks that was 12 years ago
that's 30 times what i owed
30 x
the day cove it happened the economy
shut down the world started going crazy
dude the the government started saying
mortgage moratorium eviction moratoriums
like
i had six banks call me and one day mr
cardone we'd like to come to your office
see how we can work help you work
through this
get big baby okay it's the 10x rule man
the 10x rule says go big or go home no
go bigger go bigger
never go home man ain't nothing at home
looking for drugs finding drugs losing
drugs like
losing the drugs yeah find them buy them
lying to people hiding from people
uh you know it was terrible it was
terrible i did that for nine and a half
years it was awful so it's the worst
part of my life it's the darkest worst
part of my life
and so i had to crawl out and and then i
replaced literally when i was 25 years
old
i started every day with a meeting and i
ended every day with a meeting
i'd go to a narcotics anonymous meeting
or some kind of 12-step program for
i'll bet you i did that for
15 or 16 years so you were all in
committed i'm going to
a meeting in the morning and at night
i'm either i'm going there to help
myself and i'm gonna help somebody else
every day wow 15 years yeah and then and
then um
that was my form of helping people i'm
like i might help other people that have
this problem that really kept me from
going back concept and i understand the
affirmations and mental and be positive
and meditation how about some action
yeah
you know like like i you know i have
never thought something into existence
without doing something okay once you be
the greatest youtuber in the world the
greatest skateboarder in the world do
like something that's real don't be a
liar
everybody's gonna know it and the higher
the food the higher up you go in the
food chain the harder it is to trick
people i don't know if i was 15 years
old today i'd be probably i'd probably
be teaching people
i'd first i'd go after the kid market
which really is a parent market
i talked to parents
and i'd probably create a youtube
channel about
uh how parents
uh how kids can
parents can get their kids to to learn
faster
and and you know
maybe come up with some tricks and hacks
and ebooks and courses to create a big
audience i don't know that i'd sell
anything in the beginning maybe i would
but
but i need to create a big audience so
then later someone either someone else
or myself can sell something to them but
look if it doesn't include an audience
you don't have a business so i think the
first thing people need to do is figure
out how to create an audience hey it's
been said it's been said by people for
thousands of years
what you think it is what you get if
look behind me and you will see dreams
being made into reality
imagine that back here in london
uh i don't know a thousand years ago 800
years ago i don't actually know my
history that well
none of this existed somebody dreamed
about it somebody probably
thought about wow one day we'll have a
village there one day we'll have a city
there
so today i want to talk to you about in
this
video i want to talk to you about your
dreams what you're thinking about what
are you imagining
i imagine i make up in my mind that
somebody thought about a little small
township not ever imagining that one day
there would be towers and glass and
steel and spheres and oh my gosh a city
with what 20 million people in it
literally where all the money in the
universe all the money on this planet
moves through this city the highly
successful people dream they imagine
they spend time literally writing out
what their future might look like now
i'm not talking about when i talk about
dreaming in this segment i'm not talking
about when you sleep and dream i'm not
talking about nightmares i'm not talking
about daydreaming
i'm talking about you envisioning what
your future might be like
when you see other people and you're
like god i wish i could do that or i
wish i could have that
other people if you speak about that out
loud they're they're going to try to
talk you out of it they're going to tell
you things like oh that's too much and
that's ridiculous i thought oh i'm going
to dream people are going to try to talk
me out of it because i had people trying
to talk me out of real estate
being on stage speaking in front of tens
of thousands of people running my own
events uh creating millions hundreds of
millions of dollars in network i had
people trying to talk me out of that
because i thought that they were jealous
or envious or that they're like okay if
grant gets it i can't have it but the
truth is
most the people that are trying to talk
me out of my dreams and my
visualizations and me spending time on
actually imagining
what i could achieve
they weren't trying to talk me out of it
because they couldn't have it they were
trying to talk me out of it because they
quit okay it's crazy look it's not true
when somebody tells you you can't have
everything you want look at this
look behind me look at the ships look at
the water look at the river okay look at
the the commerce look at the
monetization that's happening back here
the new buildings that are being built
the the the glass and the steel and
buildings going up way higher than
anybody ever imagined possible
focus on your dreams the highly
successful people do this they think
about what is possible and then they get
themselves around other people that are
dreaming you can't just dream on your
own you got to get around other people
that actually allow your dream to
breathe and helps you with your
imagination you can't really paint okay
or create art in a vacuum you need ideas
you need to see what other people are
thinking and doing in order to
see what you could imagine or put down
on paper
look the fact is you're going to get
what you focus on you're getting it
right now whatever you have today
is what you focused on thought about in
your mind
activated
in real life
and then reinforced on a daily basis if
you're in poverty today it's because you
probably grew up in poverty thought
about poverty think you're only poverty
think that you can only have poverty and
yes guess what that's what you had bill
gates said if you're born poor it's not
your fault if you stay poor yes it is
your fault that is see this is already
taking place in your life your your
dreams
if you take responsibility your dreams
if you're willing to take full
responsibility for what you have right
now
hey the fact is what you've been
dreaming
daydreaming night dreaming
work dreaming thinking about what you've
been talking about what you've been
focusing on throughout your 24 hour
period each day is what you're getting
look no person is happy without a goal
no person is going to be happy if
they're not working on being happy
people that have faith in the ability to
reach a goal
people that have faith in the ability to
win to reach a goal to hit a milestone
to achieve something those people are
happy so it's not just dreaming it's
like going to work every day and saying
hey i have a dream i have a goal i have
a target and i want to achieve that and
i'm going to do whatever it takes to
make sure i do achieve that have you
ever acted your way into a hole i mean
because you just make decisions you ever
made one too quick and it's like oh that
was the wrong one
more often than not dude i you know
those my instincts are right
and if they're not at least i have the
skill set to reverse quickly
because if you take a long time to make
a decision you're going to take a long
time to unwind one
set of ones if you take a long time to
make a bad decision
you're going to take a long time to
unwind it yeah right if i make a bad
decision quickly i bought a truck
i'm making making this up boom i'm going
to buy that truck i've made a decision
quickly to buy it i can also make a
decision quickly to get rid of it
i bought a culinary
rolls-royce culinas 446 thousand dollars
i bought it before my growth conference
i bought it in the afternoon like i'm
gonna buy that i'm gonna put it on stage
i got it i'm like this is stupid half a
million dollars for a truck is stupid
i sold the next day
i bought it sold it boom i wrote it off
though right right i wrote it up because
it was at my conference
so so i'm just saying like if you get
used to taking a lot of time to make
decisions
if how you buy things is how you're
going to sell things
and how you make decisions is how your
organization is going to make decisions
i've been a sales guy for a long time
and i i just learned early on and i was
terrible at sales 17 years old 18 19
part-time part-time sales guy was i was
awful
when i finally realized that sales was
the only job i could get at 25 years old
i'm just like dude i just got to tell
people the truth because i can't do all
these tricks
the nlp
the and look if it works for you good
whatever but the mirroring the matching
they ask a question you ask a question
the hot potato i've heard all these
strategies
and i'm like dude i just can't do it i'm
just going to be me hey guys i'm i'm
moving from la i'm out of work i'm
looking for opportunity i'm trying to
move my family here my name's louis
curtis
2008 beat me up i got to get my family
out of la real estate's impossible i
can't buy it there it's out priced out
of the market and i'm here in pueblo
because i think there's opportunity here
and that's all i'm looking for no
handouts no help i don't i got an old
truck with me i got no money i left my
kids with you got to have your story it
can't just be one strategy you're no
longer just a phone person or an
in-person person or an internet person
if you're heavily dependent upon the
internet do not abandon your other mixed
choices this is like mixed martial arts
we call it mixed martial selling that's
right mixed martial selling i am the
mixed martial arts
of sales
because i use the phone i use the
internet i use social different than the
internet and number four i use a
personal visit i will walk in knock on
your door
and number five i use referrals so what
are your different mixed martial arts if
you will your mixed arts of sales today
the internet's one the phone's one
retail traditional retail visits for
social media and number five referrals
influencers getting other people to
endorse you okay
rich people do not value money the way
poor people do they they they invest
money they don't spend it
you know the best the best spending is
still worse than the best and the the
worst investment like you could make a
bad investment that would still be
better than a smart spend you know you
spend money when you spend money you
don't get an investment back
and when you invest money at least you
got a possibility i mean the very at the
very least you get a tax write-off
so if i spend money on a belt
i can't write it off i can only wear it
and if i invest money in a grant cardone
belt
and wear it on stage and it flops as a
product and nobody ever buys it
it's at least a write-off it was at
least a promotion so a bad investment is
still better than a smart spin so uh
wealthy people don't spend money they
invest money i was married to my
business
[Music]
i was not going to do this until i had
money
was that a good decision
one thousand percent or like if would if
you had a relationship you're not
accelerating no no no no no explain that
because i was the dream and i believed
this i told my wife when i got with her
i said look i'll do anything for you
except one thing
i will not give up on that dream
if i got to surrender my dream
i'd rather be alone
because if i abandon my dream i'll
abandon you i truly believe that i see
so many people man they give up their
dream for the wife they give up their
dream for the husband they give up their
and then and then the wife and the
husband get together and they have kids
and then they give up their dream again
because of the kids and i said the day
we have kids we cannot blame the kids
for not going after our potential and
our dreams if we ever have kids when we
were getting together
and she wasn't ready to have kids she
wasn't even ready for me
and so i knew she was the right person
for me and i'm like look i'll give you
anything monogamy i'll never cheat on
you i'll never jack around on you i'll
take care of you i'll provide you with a
life that you can only dream of
this was 12 years ago i mean this is way
before grant really hit full grant and
and which she's really um
added to and made it easier but um
i said look if you if i got to be less
than who i'm meant to be
to be with you
that's powerful can't give you that
that's strong so i said i got books in
me this was before i'd ever written a
book i said i got books in me i'm going
to do the biggest events in the world
i'm going to do a tv show okay i will i
will be known by millions if not
billions of people
and i will leave a legacy
and and and that
that has been with me before i ever met
you
amazing and i'm not giving that up
because if i give that up i'll give you
up training
if you're not going to train
then put a sign on your desk i quit
learning a long time ago and see how
many people want to buy from
tell your family go home and tell your
wife and your kids i quit learning i
quit reading i quit studying i quit
training i can't get any better
put on there done i'm finished i'm in
retirement early i'm going to purgatory
i'm going to wait it out cross my
fingers and hope they bring me to sales
heaven look you're done if you don't
train okay now i know you know this
you've heard it i hate to tell you this
my boy mcgregor connor
conor mcgregor or mcgregor my boy conor
mcgregor okay i went and saw him fight
in new york i went and saw him fight for
one reason because i saw him say
i'm not the best this isn't about talent
it's cause i'm obsessed i out train
everyone else i have to win so bad i
train
look if you're not training that says
something about your obsession or lack
of obsession
with winning
i want you to win
i know your your wife or your husband
your spouse your family members your
kids your mom and dad want you to win at
the next level no matter what they tell
you
even if they tell you you're doing great
pat you in the back you know the truth
you know the truth the only way to win
is to train the only way to win is to
read the only way to win is to learn
learn more listen more
learn something new look we're in a
we're in a time like we've never been
before
technologies come and go faster than
people do
things are changing like this whether
it's video you're using or social media
or snap or or short videos or videos
that disappear or videos that stay or
text messaging that you can create to
push and market and brand yourself
called text messaging which i've been
using a lot
look the world's changing and if you're
saying to yourself i'm too old to learn
that well then guess what you're too old
to learn that if you can't learn
anything new just put i'm ripe and i'm
about to fall off the tree and nobody's
gonna want me look man you gotta train
every single day like your life depends
on it
train every single day i am here today
i own these four companies that i own
the studio my reputation everything is
because when i was 25 years old to when
i was 30 years old every single day
i trained watching video every day i'd
watch the video i'd walk in and then i
would role play and then we would do a
sales meeting every single day what were
the lessons you learned
you know starting from essentially zero
having no money no context
no uh relationships no
uh opportunities in a town that you went
to for this show what did you realize
were the keys to actually making money
even if you didn't have any well as you
see the show you see that i actually
never make any money right so
uh the two girls they they actually they
they follow three of us and the two
girls went out and got a job in the
first week
and and i'm not saying that's right or
wrong or my way is more better or worse
but but they are strategies okay they're
different strategies i was not there to
get a job or to earn money
i was there looking for one thing
opportunity i never spent time looking
for money ever the entire
uh 90 days okay i'm not looking for
money i was actually looking for
contracts through the contacts i wasn't
looking for money because i knew the
evaluation of the company in the last
segment
an evaluator will come in and determine
what my company's worth my new company
right that i created
and at that point i just need to
validate to him
dude my company's worth this based on
that the entire 90 days
i never touched the first hundred they
gave me
and this was to prove to people dude you
do not need money like it's just it's
not true you need money you do need
contacts
you need people you need people you need
people you need the right people though
the right people that are already in
play
okay just because a guy's got money
i remember a billionaire friend of mine
uh you know he could buy a jet
and i said hey bob should i buy a jet he
said you should i shouldn't
meaning grant should because and he's
way wealthier than i am he could have
bought 40 of them he's like i don't have
a place to go in mine you have a you
could use yours every day
so you got to find somebody that's in
place somebody that not just has money
but somebody wants to do more with their
money
so you'll notice in the first 10 days i
don't spend a hun any money i don't
spend money on shelter not on food and
not on water
nothing then what i do is i end up
accumulating assets and it's unfortunate
that the viewer doesn't see this within
five days i have two vehicles one was
given to me by the discovery and the
other one was a forty thousand dollar
jeep
that i basically used
uh from ryan this guy i met
and told him i'm gonna sell your jeep
i'm gonna drive it around town and put
ten miles a day on it and i'm gonna sell
it well that's a forty three thousand
dollar asset
uh my truck was worth four grand i still
had my hundred dollars i lived in a
forty six thousand dollar rv
that i was trying to sell
so yeah uh and what what's the other
thing i did and i picked up ten thousand
dollars
to do in a fifteen percent partnership
in the equity of the upside of this
guy's company so literally in 10 days
i was accumulating contacts that could
get me equity and the important part of
that story is man go get you some equity
you know jay-z talks about this you're
getting you know so many of you young
brothers are getting in advance while
i'm picking up the equity three parts to
the real estate game number one
is the deal
i found me a good one right here i'm in
the heights one of the most desirable
neighborhoods in all of the 713.
number one's the deal number two is the
debt you got to get a bank that's
willing to lend on that we're working on
that right now
the debt market's insane right now now
and i'm still learning how to play that
game
making connections getting relationships
with people i've had money pointed to me
at three and three three and three
quarters
all the way down to two point
uh seven five and then last night got
some money quoted to me at under two
percent in
saying in the membrane changes
everything in the game when you get your
debt right the third part of the deal is
cash
equity how much can you put down to buy
the deal so many of you out there be
looking at deals this size if you knew
how to get the debt and the equity but
because you you think you're short on
debt and equity
you reduce the deal size or the location
or the quality of the asset most of you
are chasing the death equity when the
truth mission should be chasing the deal
because the right deal with the right
story in the right location the right
traffic the right renter
then it'll always bring the money i'll
tell you a story i just did a deal in
boca raton i paid 70 million dollars for
the deal
and i knew like i moved on this deal so
fast it was unbelievable because i knew
that market right i didn't have to do a
lot of research because i'd already done
the research so i still did the research
right because i'd already done a
research you know what i'm saying i'm
gonna go check out this restaurant right
now see how they're doing and um
bought the deal closed the deal very
little due diligence by the way
just wham
looking for reasons to buy the deal
because i knew the location we raised
the rents
500 a month already i've been in 60 days
we just had one maybe two rent two rent
uh leases come in at a thousand dollars
more
than they were before we bought them and
we got great plans for the property
we're going to do great stuff for the
tenants there
point is
when you raise the rents man guess what
you make the property better you have
more money to take care of your tenants
it improves the value of the property
and gives you some momentum in that
property
uh
and then momentum to buy more deals
point is
dude find the right deal in the right
location at the right time and the right
price the debt and the equity problem i
called the lender today he's like i paid
69 million they're like we'll give you
60 million dollars for the debt on that
deal based on its performance just in
the last 60 days since you took
ownership
that is on unbelievable that means i
only need nine million dollars to buy
the deal and i've already raised again
uh know your location
get some support around you uh real
estate is a team sport okay it's about
relationships about the debts about
relationships equity's about
relationship deals without relationships
okay so what are we doing exactly so i
don't think that's gone
and we're having we're having uh papa
papa's been
watching us what is it called
being our papa
yeah i don't know he's just it's been
like only him with us
and
and so we're pulling a little prank on
mother we have i've wrapped
scarlett's arm the lower half of the arm
she probably won't find that funny but
we think it is
and so they decided to put makeup on me
because miss scarlett's got the makeup
of a 30 year old maybe 35 year old
true and
you know you dad's out there
you busy dads that are all trying to
find the life balance thing
how do you make enough time for your
kids
you know the question is is is
is it really about time or is it about
what you do with them
because i tend to think it's more about
what you do with them
then
can we see your makeup
are we going to try to do the same thing
on youtube
scarlett
oh my gosh you're going crazy huh
let's let's see how you're looking
sabrina helped me a little bit is that
what we're going to get
i helped you because you were done so
guys do you guys want more time with me
or is it or is it is it the things we do
with the time we have which one's more
important i want more time with you
well
i feel like we're gonna have fun if
we're together yeah
yeah no matter what by the way this is a
freak big broken arm but last night we
watched a good movie what was it it was
called soul yeah what did you love it
yeah it's a pixar movie it was super
it's a pixar and disney yeah we were
gonna watch it again it was such a good
feeling movie jamie foxx was a
lead voice
he was a jazz guy he was a jazzy uh oh
oh this is coming loose so this is the
prank that we're pulling on mama it's
not gonna run for long because i feel
mean no no it's all right it's all right
oh that's good matches your makeup too
what color should we do father should i
do your onion as well i don't know you
guys do whatever you wanna do they
usually do the
well if you broke your hand we would if
you broke your wrist and then i would
have to like
i would cover it
i don't think so yeah so the question
scarlett that everybody wants to know is
how do you make how does a parent make
time for the kids and then
do you want more time or is it things
like this that you'll remember doing
what's your right closure or will you
even remember this i don't remember i'll
remember i remember i'm gonna do it to
your eyebrow can you see that i tucked
it in a little is that visible
and
do i spend enough time with you guys
that's the question okay let me give you
some answers let's get it honest let's
get it honest so we're talking to the
parents and the kids out there first of
all is it hard being a kid yes yes is it
hard being a parent yeah which one's
harder
in your mind
probably
i say adult
you think being being the parents harder
than me in the kit
um i guess being a parent's heart this
guy takes the best photographs in the
world
this guy takes the best video in the
world what i've done with you huh that's
little johnny the camera guy see i had
the same conversation
he's like graham man i'd love to bring
you in man but you're not black man i
said yeah what doesn't matter what color
i am dude i like like why we care
people need information i don't i don't
look at people i don't look at like hey
i look at money people make money look
my mother raised me to love people for
who they are
period
what cover they are who are they yeah
what is your spirit what is your soul
what is your intake yeah because this
don't mean
when money gets involved color goes away
thank you
ain't nobody ever seen an ugly
billionaire green neighbor
i never seen an ugly dog
ugly hey man i love you man let's do
some more stuff together all right let's
play something it ain't no accident
ain't no accident why
you reached out and i got back and we're
doing it again good now it's time to
expand and do it bigger you say multiply
let's multiply and for the right people
you're right these people are all paying
because there's some kids there's some
kids that campaign that need to get they
need the data first yeah because their
mama's teaching them how to save money
they'll never make them make money
blackstone's taking retirement money
it's all [ __ ]
[Music]
one of the best homes on this property
still a one
it's great property
it's not on the ocean but it's big about
10 000 square feet
i think they get
11 grand a night there
it's got five bedrooms beautiful pool
infinity pool
beautiful property i mean everything
here is gorgeous you can't do go wrong
when you come down here
uh the landscaping is phenomenal it's
got the natal pumps plums natal plum
sort the variegated we got
massive numbers of palm trees
hibiscus bougainvillea
we got it all here we got the birds of
paradise we got the ginger we got the
red burger beet the perpendia the white
bougainvillea the pink bougainvillea the
orange bougainvillea you got it all
and it's poppin and rockin best months
of the year
december january february march cabo san
lucas welcome to mexico but i'm about to
bring you into a villa this is oleander
by the way poisonous to children
i don't know if you knew that or not
and i don't know if you knew oh look at
this big guy hey bud
there you go
uh i don't know if you know this but i
am a landscape
what is it called junkie i love that
just absolutely
one of the most fascinating things if i
if i wasn't into the money game i'd
probably have a big landscaping business
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you're special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want some amazing lewis howes motivation
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there but i
regret that i didn't share this with my
girlfriend
my husband my wife my kids that i didn't
go back to school that i didn't write
the book launch the podcast whatever it
is what i regret it